[Música]
salud tendría hito américa de france 24
está con nosotros en el estudio más
romeros a la mar vamos a hablar de un
tema que pues muchos se quedarán un poco
extrañados vamos a hablar de lo que
comemos especialmente de la sal y sus
riesgos si raúl así es que se ha
publicado un estudio nuevo en la revista
heart de bien jake y ha generado mucho
revuelo porque digamos que baja un poco
en contra de algunas recomendaciones que
solíamos de escuchar con él es mejor
apartar la sal de la dieta en este caso
lo que concluyen es que hay un tipo de
patología particular que si no se les
restringe la sal pues les va mejor en el
futuro al cabo de los años
particularmente estamos hablando de una
insuficiencia cardíaca en la que la
cámara inferior del corazón no puede
bombear bien la sangre y eso hace pues
que falte sangre en todo el cuerpo aquí
vemos uno de los gráficos publicados
básicamente en la línea azul es la gente
que sí usaba sal y la línea roja es la
gente que cocinaba con sal entonces
vemos que la diferencia está la gente o
sea las muertes cardiovasculares en las
personas que nos avanzan que apartaban
la sal de la dieta estaba por debajo de
las personas que efectivamente sí habían
usado sal a diferencia de más aumentando
con los años sucede algo parecido con
las hospitalizaciones por esta
precisamente insuficiencia cardíaca que
les estábamos comentando en este caso la
diferencia se mantiene más o menos
estable a lo largo del tiempo con un
aumento progresivo después pero sin
embargo sigue pasando lo mismo no parece
que las personas que consumían sal de
una forma moderada seguían teniendo
menos hospitalizaciones que las personas
que efectivamente se habían apartado
como recomiendan los médicos
generalmente esto como siempre que nos
dicen algo que nos gusta y que no
debemos consumirlo pues todo el mundo
muy rápidamente se ha precipitado a
creérselo pero bueno también si tienes
digamos esta condición por cierto una
amiga mía una vez me comentó que ella
hacía eso porque tiene una condición en
las orillas de lo que estamos hablando
pero le pregunto marchi es
verdaderamente fiable este estudio luego
le pasa de este espacio
y luego aumentamos pues como siempre
aquí en salud de france 24 revisamos
bien cómo están construidos los estudios
también lo hicimos basándonos en la
información de los años media center de
un portal el científico español y ahí
uno de sus expertos es un cardiólogo
estaba explicando qué hay varios sesgos
en la construcción de este estudio que
pueden afectar sus resultados uno es un
sesgo de precisión parece que no está
tan bien contado la cantidad de sal
entonces que podría haber allí un error
como en los datos que concluyen todas
estas informaciones otra parte es un
sesgo que puede ser de edad en este tipo
de insuficiencia cardiaca que influye
mucho en la edad de los pacientes
también otros factores como qué tipo de
enfermedad ha provocado esta
insuficiencia cardíaca cómo ha
progresado con el tiempo y eso no se
tiene tan en cuenta y por último es un
estudio observacional qué significa eso
pues que comparan cogen un hábito de las
personas y ven qué sucede con su salud
cardiovascular a lo largo del tiempo
pero ahí podrían perderse muchos otros
factores que influyen en la salud
cardiovascular de las personas y que
podrían estar también influyendo en
estos resultados es por eso pues que por
ahora nos vamos a quedar con las
recomendaciones generales
internacionales de que un consumo bajo o
nulo incluso de sal es lo mejor para
nuestra salud cardiovascular porque
expliquemos lo brevemente pues la sal
hace que el cuerpo retenga agua cuando
hay más agua y más líquido en el cuerpo
a la presión arterial y ese aumento de
presión arterial es lo que hace que
luego nuestro corazón se tenga que
esforzar más que los vasos sanguíneos
también reciban más presión y por lo
tanto también tengan ese esfuerzo extra
que a largo plazo puede afectarnos en
nuestra salud del corazón y
cardiovascular en general marc y como
siempre lo decimos aquí también es mejor
que vayan a su médico porque pues tiene
que haber un diagnóstico también
individual acorde a nosotros por
supuesto vamos a volver a hablar del coi
19 esta vez para la sub variante beas 5
si otra cosa que también está inundando
titulares así que bueno aquí la traemos
para analizarlo con un poquito más de
calma y no es por poco que está llamando
tanto la atención es de su variante que
está empujando las oleadas de contagios
en europa en eeuu y ahora parece que
está llegando a américa latina por
ejemplo a colombia vamos a repasar las
cifras de este país vemos unas cifras
del instituto nacional de salud de
colombia y vemos como desde febrero de
2022 de este año van recogiendo las
distintas sus variantes todas de omicron
por cierto que representan los contagios
de kobe 19 en el país
de mayo aproximadamente es que este azul
verdoso que es la variante ve a 4 y ve a
cinco que son muy parecidas van cogiendo
terreno hasta representar en la última
semana de julio casi el 78% de los
contagios de kobe 19 en el país algo que
está pasando por ejemplo también en eeuu
con una cifra parecida y pues obviamente
ya la han apodado la peor variante de
kobe 19 su variante de hecho que hemos
visto hasta ahora sin duda como vemos en
este gráfico parece que está teniendo
una ventaja de contagios al menos de
transmisibilidad respecto otras
variantes anteriores mari que sabemos
que de su variante puede ser de forma
relativamente resumida luego seguiremos
informando sobre esto las preocupaciones
son sobre todo alrededor de su escape
inmune es decir la facilidad que tienen
para evadir la inmunidad que podemos
adquirir pues por una infección previa o
por las vacunas de 19 de hecho parece
que la infección está siendo cada vez
más común no haber tenido jacoby y
después volver a contagiarse sin embargo
no hay evidencia de que por ahora
provoque una enfermedad más grave más
severa tampoco y evidencia de lo
contrario tampoco hay evidencia de que
estemos andando hacia un virus que se
parece más a la gripe y que por lo tanto
sea menos grave tampoco tenemos pues
conclusiones claras sobre esto sin
embargo más contagios como siempre
significan más hospitalizaciones
significa más presión sobre el sistema
sanitario y ya sabemos la dinámica ya
sabemos la historia después de dos años
de pandemia todo está a presión sobre el
sistema hospitalario puede también
resultar en más muertes tanto por kobe
19 pero también problemas de salud pues
en otros aspectos que podemos ver a
mediano plazo de otras enfermedades que
quedan desatendidas cuando hay estas
oleadas al final pues estamos jugando un
poco con fuego no cada vez que hay una
transmisión hay el riesgo de que una
variante nueva aparezca y parece que
ahora mismo los expertos dicen que se
nos abren dos caminos hacia adelante uno
que aparezca en estas sus variantes que
por ahora hemos tenido cierta suerte no
las vacunas parece que aguantes bien que
más o menos siga manteniéndose otra en
cambio otro camino es que en algún
momento explote una nueva variante un
poco como pareció economy crohn o más
grave que nos vuelva a llevar a un
escenario de verdadera crisis sanitaria
y esperemos que no sea ese camino mar
muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la información saludo nuestro segundo
invitado al día